what would you say to the critics that
say that this offensive explosion in the
NBA is due to a lack of Defense that's
lame excuse I think that's just because
the talent level is so crazy like what
guys are capable of doing and the
cerebral ability of some of these guys
that also have talent and it's tough to
guard these guys you can't say that this
year it's been my best year playing
defense you can hate all you want I mean
that's just what it is I've taken
charges being there for my teammates we
can all be better I can be better on
that end still we haven't won enough
games for me to say I'm first team or
anything but definitely getting better
definitely been a thing on my
mind